Mary Jeanne is the
system administrator
for a big website.
The website requires multiple
web servers and database
servers to run.
Each web server
costs $40 per month,
and each database
costs $60 per month.
To get an idea of the monthly
bill her company will have
to pay, Mary Jeanne
makes a little table.
So this is the number of
potential web servers,
and this is the number
of the database servers.
So these are
different scenarios.
What is the expression
that describes
a monthly hosting bill for n web
servers and m database servers?
So let's think about
what's going on right here.
When she has one web server
and one database server,
well, she has to pay $40 per
month for that one web server
and $60 a month for that
one database server.
Now, when you add that
together, you get $100.
Now, here, in the
second scenario,
she has two web servers
and one database server.
So here, she's
multiplying 40 times
2, because that's how
many web servers she has.
So she's going to have to pay
$80 a month for the web servers
and still $60 per month for
the one database server.
Let's skip to one
that's more interesting.
So here she has five web servers
and two database servers.
So she pays $48 per month for
each of the five web servers.
And she pays $60 a month
for each of the two database
servers.
So if you wanted to write
an expression that describes
the monthly hosting bill for
n web servers and m database
servers, well, you see
here, you see this pattern.
She pays $40 per month for
every web server that she has.
So if she has n
web servers, she's
going to pay $40 per month
per server times n servers.
And then she's paying $60 a
month per database server.
So if she has m
database servers,
she's going to pay $60
per month per server times
the number of servers.
So this right over
here is the expression
for the monthly
hosting billing cost.
And you could see
that right over here.
If you view this is as n,
the number of web servers,
and this as m, you see that
when n is 20 and m is 10,
then you get 40 times 20
plus 60 times 10-- 40 times n
plus 60 times m.
And then you would
get your actual value.